hi I'm Conan O'Brien or as I'm or as I'm
known here at comic-con the hound in the
streets and Littlefinger in the sheets
I really should figure out what these
mean by right right exactly
ladies I miss you a night of not being
affected no we're very excited we have
the cast of Game of Thrones here
in fact in honor of the show tonight our
entire audience is made up of actors who
were killed on Game of Thrones
nicely done yeah yeah and that was just
in last week's episode yeah kind of very
exciting weekend across the country did
you know the Sandy yes yeah very
exciting there was some major releases
this weekend Dunkirk girls trip
yeah Oh Jay Simpson another guy another
guy on his way out is Sean Spicer Sean
Spicer
Sean Spicer has resigned as the White
House press secretary but don't worry he
already got a new job defending the good
work of Hydra that is
[Applause]
what a swag what a swag at this year's
comic-con this year at comic-con DC
unveiled 41 new collectables yeah yes
the collectibles the collectibles are in
pristine untouched condition just like
the people collecting them
[Applause]
I've had a really strange week here at
Comic Con at my hotel true story I got
hit on by a brony yeah yeah I had to
tell him neigh means neigh I was waiting
[Applause]
I haven't wanted to do that all week
you